there's some initial reports i haven't
been able to independently verify this
but
we're hearing that president donald
trump was trying to use the potus
account
and that he was tweeting from it but
twitter removed the tweet
instantaneously that it happened again
that's just some of the reports that are
coming in right now from the at potus
account
now the potus account is still active
the latest allegations and reports that
are coming in now that i have not
verified is that he did tweet and it was
deleted by
twitter that would be a shadow now so
that's what i'm hearing right now
um is happening who's who's reporting it
though
i just had it here i just uh went up
here i already saw like three people
tweet it
um well we'll search for it and we'll
see what we can find so he's been
seeing people reportedly shadow band on
his other account
well it's not his account it's our
account yes we have images here josh
kaplan
verified twitter user he is a homepage
editor for breitbart news tweets twitter
deletes series of tweets presumably
written by president trump on the potus
account
following the permanent ban of his
account wow he tweeted 8 29 pm today
as i've been saying for a long time
twitter has gone further and further in
banning free speech and tonight twitter
employees have coordinated with the
democrats and the radical left
in removing my account from their
platform to silence me and you the 75
million great
patriots who voted for me twitter may be
a private company but without the
government's gift of section 230 they
would not exist for long
i predicted this would happen we have
been negotiating with various other
sites
and i will have a big announcement soon
while we also look at the possibilities
of building our own
building out our own platform in the
near future we will not be silenced
twitter is not about free speech they
are all about promoting a radical left
platform where some of the most vicious
people in the world are allowed to speak
freely
stay tuned this did come from
the president to the potus account and
it has been removed and another thing
that we're hearing is that he might
give a publicly televised address soon
but the thing is
who's going to hear it because when we
saw during the
election many news organizations just
cut them out they said no we're not
going to play the president's address
we're just going to stop it here what
the president
is saying is wrong we don't agree with
it and there is huge editorializing even
on fox news
interrupting the president saying no
this is one reason second reason third
reason why the president is wrong
what's going to happen if he does a
national address now
i mean i'll tell you when i hear it i'll
tell you you know you know what i'm
worried about before
the mass purge they just pulled off i
think many people
were willing to accept that trump had
finally been defeated
mike cernovich for instance one of the
most prominent trump supporters
ever sin in the trump era he put up a
poll and he said
did donald trump concede yes no
unsure show me the results something
like that and around
25 said no
donald trump made a video where he said
there will be a new administration and
we will peacefully transition
i made a video trump confirms defeat
mike pence certifies joe biden
trump said it i don't know what i was
supposed to take from that but many
trump supporters around 25 percent
of mike cernovich's you know polled said
he didn't concede
mike responded by saying to those who
believe this
i love you please on unfollow people who
have
made you believe this go home to your
loved ones they miss you
and you know it's time to stop
essentially i'm paraphrasing
he's right there are people who are
ardent and prominent trump supporters
who are saying guys please
please enough okay trump has said he's
lost it's over
then they do this then twitter comes out
and does this and they do more and they
do more
now they're purging people left and
right and i think many of those people
who are probably like yeah
you know i was probably dumb at the
capitol i guess it's over now they're
enraged
now they're angry you you took like it's
like here's how i imagine it
you've got a guy in a bar right and he's
he's disparaging you and then you're
about to fight and then he goes you know
what you know what i'm not doing this
i'm out of here he turns around and
walks away so you throw a
can at his head and then he turns around
and says that's it that's what we had
people were right not everybody was
walking away for sure a lot of people
were saying crazy things
but a lot of people were like all right
all right walking away and then twitter
was like not yet
whipped them in the head and then they
turned around and now i think they're
gonna explode
and now my concern is after seeing this
there is real fear about multinational
corporations
shutting down the president it should
not be allowed in my opinion
by u.s law that our executive or chief
executive could be shut down on a major
communication platform
that has essentially seized the commons
in terms of communication this is a
major power grab
we have to understand historically when
an entity or a force go after power and
they get it
they go after more you know there's an
expression if you give your pinky you're
going to
give up your whole hand eventually
exactly so so
this is a slippery slope this is the
snowball
that's been happening ever since 2008
and it's been snowballing and it's
getting big and it's only going to get
bigger because who's going to stand in
the way
who's going to promote free speech who's
going to uphold it who's going to
protect it
what institutions are out there that
could actually make a stand here
i don't see fox news doing that at all i
don't see
any other website all of the means of
communication have been hijacked
and are in the hands of special
interests and few people is there any
hope guys
let me tell you something when trump won
there were a lot of trump supporters
being mean and snide and mocking and
belittling as people screamed and cried
and memes went crazy
and now we're seeing the same we're
seeing a lot of the same on the other
side
but now it's not coming from random
people on the internet it's coming from
cnn we have asha rengappa
she is i'm pretty sure let me make sure
yes fbi uh former fbi special 8 special
agent and cnn analyst
said i'm not even going to screenshot
what he's tweeting from the potus
account twitter's already taking it down
but boo boo mad this is the kind of
dismissive
and insulting and humiliating
humiliating content
coming from prominent institutions which
will trigger
mass rage i don't care if
random twitter user 123 tweets nasty
things at me
i don't care i don't know who you are i
don't care
to make youtube videos about random
twitter users who say dumb things
but when it's someone who works for a
major cultural institution or polit or
politics and they have power
and influence i think it needs to be
talked about and called out they
disagree
and the funny thing is this is actually
a left-wing principle they say don't
punch
down then why is it that mainstream
media is punching down calling regular
americans stupid
mocking the way they live mocking the
way they work mocking their lives now i
get it
mocking the president is not punching
down by all means
mock him my concern is when cnn comes
out and attacks the people who are angry
you can't also another thing you can't
really fight fascism with fascism
like that's something also a lot of
people need to realize here you can
except those who don't like fascism are
going to be really angry about it you're
going to get fascism
but right right listen if authoritarian
leftists want authoritarianism
and they just don't want authoritarian
rights to win well then there you go
i don't think orthogonalism is the best
i don't think a lot of people realize
the larger kind of implications here i
don't think a lot of people realize
uh where this is going and the
historical president that this is
setting as well so augmented way you
said luke you can fight
fascism with fascism but you can't
defeat fascism with fascism
yes good good yeah or that's better you
can fight fashion with
if in a fascism fight all you'll get is
fascism
there you go so to talk a little bit
about the fact-checking
strike quote-unquote fact-checking
strategies at facebook
and twitter like what they're doing is
basically bringing in a small group of
think tanks and it's it's it's it's not
a real system so what we're actually
talking about doing is working with
uh this group ground.news i don't know
if you've ever heard of them
they for every article they
their algorithm grabs all the articles
and shows on both sides
and they sort of are doing the best it
seems good faith effort to
show all the coverage on both sides and
so
that when you're scrolling down your
feed you can get
context to what you're seeing
and i you know that's where we need to
be going giving people
access to all of the data around the
post so that they have
the most information not just saying
this is true or this is false facebook
knew what they were doing
facebook knew early on that they were
feeding ex
you know hyper partisan content to
different sides in fact
there are some news organizations that
knew this too and created two different
versions
of their content because one would feed
to the left and one would feed to the
right
and there was a thing they would do it's
just general journalism a b
testing where they'll write an article
and in some regions
they would use certain titles different
in other regions total different framing
to see how it would perform to maximize
the amount of ads they would get
the amount of clicks they would get and
in turn the revenue because they knew
that somebody who lived in texas
would probably see you know rather see
an article that says
nancy pelosi is bad and the people lived
in san francisco probably would like to
see nancy pelosi good
they were doing like experiments on
users facebook oh yes
where they would feed them emotionally
charged uh articles
to to see if it would produce more
clicks
now they've got uh you know artificial
intelligence or whatever this this
algorithm is that's private
you know tweaking and and deciding what
people see and
what what gets flagged so i'll tell you
you know what you know who our
government really is
it's the robots it's whose controls the
narrative yeah it's well what is
govern is the control the mind control
of the system right now
if if facebook uses an ai to feed
content to people
they're feeding it it might be a machine
learning
listen okay speaking colloquially
facebook creates an algorithm that feeds
certain content
all that matters is is what i've said
jack dorsey
has swallowed so much of his own refuse
i think he's actually been radicalized
by what he's created
i i've if you look at him compared to
where he was when twitter launched to
where he is now he's a dramatically
different person
and why does he believe the things he
believes he created a platform that
incentivizes rage content
and then he started eating that content
which changed his brain
and then he had the keys to the castle
went in and changed more of the platform
to keep
feeding into that it's an insanity loop
he
if if he created it it radicalized him
and then he sold it and then he made it
crazier and
crazier to fit his new radicalized mind
think about what he said in the
beginning with a free speech wing of the
free speech party
but that was just a joke think about
what i said to him when i said
your misgendering rule is ideological
because conservatives
don't don't understand that view
have a totally different world view but
he couldn't see it
because he had been swimming in the
refuse he created
yep and he didn't just create it he made
the world crazier
in the instant that you brought it up
but also another aspect to understand
here
mental health has been in decline ever
since we saw the rise of social media
many people say that is a massive
correlation that's another way
that it impact people with depression
suicides and a lot of
other mental health defects that are
skyrocketing right now as we're speaking
so so if you go out you know on an
average day if you talk to a neighbor or
if you talk to a stranger
they're not as crazy as they are online
you will talk to a random person about
that you have a lot more in common you
used to
but now it's becoming less and less rare
on more on average more on average if
you go out there
if you talk to your neighbor you're more
likely to get along with them than not
the world is not as crazy and it was
purported but the reporting of it as
being as crazy makes it crazy
i i think that's how it used to be i
think you i think you're wrong now
i think this the the radicalization of
social media has now led to people just
outside at random
being tribalized and radicalized and
and not to mention people will barely
talk to each other because they have a
mask on their face
and it's like a whole other level of
isolation
in your own house so even if you're not
on on social media
you you're not you're not going everyone
comes over
is he gonna shake my hand am i allowed
to touch this guy's hand
right it's so weird or think about when
you're in uh when you're when you're in
a city where there's a political event
going on
and they think you look like a trump
supporter or they think you look like
antifa
you know where can you walk based on how
you how you appear imagine walking
around new york city wearing
actually people have done this walk
around l.a wearing a maga hat see what
happens blair white did it she got
attacked i would say a fingernail ripped
off a lot of the chaos
today and the mental health issues comes
from text and
people attempting to communicate through
text which is a new form of
communication
with humans they used to send letters
before that before you know written
language they all communicated with
with words and sounds and and we've
lost so much touch of our ability to
communicate with our words
i find i have so much um you know faith
and and love for people that make
internet video because you speak
your mind with your words and your sound
and your vibration and it's completely
different than etching something onto a
stone
for someone else to attempt to interpret
it but but even
like this is one of the reasons we don't
do skype here and we never
first of all we're not set up for it
there could be maybe some exception in
the future but we don't
because it doesn't work even hearing
their voice
you got to see their face you have to be
able to i interrupted you
were you know what i mean i did i did
notice that yes to jump in and make that
point
good that's what we're supposed to do
you can't do that in text it wouldn't
work
because the digital overlap a lot of
times there's a problem the time delays
and the the awkwardness of you know
you're staying at a camera you're not
staying at a screen you don't see their
face people don't realize that
they think when you're when you're doing
a skype debate or a zoom call that you
can see each other's face and look into
each other's eyes no you have a camera
when i go when i
when i would do a fox news or say in the
past when i did go on msnbc
or some of these other networks i'm
staring into a
black hole that's it i don't see myself
i don't see them and you know the worst
thing about these cable networks is you
can never hear anything
they give you a delay yeah you get an
earpiece you get an earpiece and it's so
quiet and you're like can you turn it up
i can't hear anything
and then they're like uh so we're gonna
go live the producer's always loud we're
gonna go live in about 10 seconds and
then you hear the husk
[Music]
and i'm like dude i can't hear you okay
you're you're ready to talk okay
you you need to be sitting down with
someone to have a real meaningful
conversation
but at the same time we're seeing all
the news networks now are
doing remote video chats and like i
agree with you it's not as good but i
mean
to ian's point a video message is more
effective or a phone call
compared to a text text message is
dangerous you cannot get a moment and
then people freak out because they over
interpret what they're doing like
sarcasm is completely lost in time well
even just like in relationships and like
people like
people's girlfriends sends them messages
like oh my god dude and we live in this
world of it now that's that's
radicalizing and making people insane
it's
it's i don't know how to how to
overemphasize how dangerous it is to
communicate with text
and rely on it as your form of
communication we're vibrating
monkey bodies that speak words for a
reason
i think text is a great way to relay
information text was a revolution but
not to communicate
feelings it is yeah it is it can be
it can be but it it depends on the
context i think that if i wanna
i can write something with a feeling in
it but if you read it you're gonna
interpret your own feeling but if i
say something to you with a feeling
you're gonna feel what i'm feeling
i wanna i wanna i was gonna pull up a
tweet based on what you said
i tweeted this if history has taught us
anything
it's that you should trust the
government in times of emergency to do
what's right
keep us well informed as the ongoing
legitimacy of the threat and give up
emergency powers once the crisis is
averted
i intentionally just said it but it it
i call it a filter i call tweets like
that a filter clearly
to anybody who is hearing me talk if i
was to say this
in real life i would say something like
if history has taught us anything
it's that you should trust the
government in times of emergency to do
what's right
keep us well informed to the ongoing
legitimacy of the threat and to give up
emergency powers once the crisis is
averted
clearly knowing i'm being facetious in a
tweet
people thought it was real now most
people retweeted it laughing they
understood
yeah the context tim's being sarcastic
facetious etc
but a lot of people saw that and they
were like dude what is wrong with you
and those people can become
crazy dangerous that they don't
understand that's i i have i have a
friend who's a prominent leftist
who told me that people don't understand
my tweets are jokes
and i'm like what am i supposed to do
when i say something so absurd and
ridiculous
like uh i i i have another one put a
smiley face at the end
i said or a goofy face yeah that's all
you gotta do so you know you know what i
do now is i actually
reply with hello you must be new to
twitter this is a joke i'm not serious
i said the good news is now that now
with democrats in full control we can
finally lock down the country for a
couple of years to make sure covet goes
away
and a lot of people are like what are
you crazy what's wrong
some people really think that stuff they
believe it right they'll tweet that out
serious so people are like is he has he
switched has he has he changed
dude what ryan long just tweeted the
funniest thing not that i
you know what did you want to be looking
at twitter right now but
jack dorsey just yelled i'm a golden god
before jumping into his pool
what so there's this phenomenon where
you can sell your company that's kind of
a problem you create this phenomenon
like twitter
jack did and then he sold it he owns
like six percent of it now he gave up
power
gave up control um yeah google was
started by
larry and sergey they've become monsters
they're gone they're not even part of
the company anymore as far as i know
they don't well they're alphabet yeah
well i don't you said they were even off
the board of alphabet
i heard that really yeah maybe confirm
but
they they silently stepped away and the
odd thing to me about
dorsey is that he's all about bitcoin
he's tweeting about signal which is
actually a great open source you know
elon was tweeting about signal the other
day like
amazing project that was signal that was
was that moxie marlinspike yeah
interesting yeah and and and so it's
like he's aware
of this but for some reason the speech
thing he doesn't get
dorsey why does he care about bitcoin
and signal
is he really in charge he's not i don't
think so i think he's a figurehead
and yeah so he got fired a long time ago
and they brought on dick costolo
and then when he left i can't remember
why i think he may have been fired
dorsey became the ceo
i think it was costolo maybe i'm getting
my people mixed up and
uh dorsey i think is was just brought on
to appear to be
in in control and really he's not i
don't think he is
i think he owns six percent yeah well
one another thing to really kind of
consider here when you look at a lot of
the big
tech companies they either have direct
involvement with the startup
of them and intelligence agencies or
they have ongoing contracts and
cooperations with
continued government agencies that they
are working hand in hand with
case and point amazon and the cia and
the depart department of defense
facebook and uh for was that startup
connected to the intelligence agency
uh that was integral on their start we
have google
and of course uh google maps uh working
with of course the us pentagon to make
that happen
and there was another one uh inquitel i
think no i don't i don't know
that's a lot of faction we have to do
for a lot of yeah i'm gonna have to look
into that stuff to be
to talk more clearly on it thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you